after today's detailed testing and brand
new discovery i'm now even more
convinced that many of you guys should
be buying a new macbook pro instead of
buying the brand new mac studio and
that'll explain exactly why and with
that who should buy a mac studio instead
of a macbook the select few we're gonna
get into some details and those new
discoveries with some of these tests and
then give you guys the pros and cons
now when these macbooks came out we were
very impressed they were amazing in
terms of battery life performance and
fan noise but they did have some
limitations we found out that the clock
speeds would actually run lower when you
max them out whereas the m1 chip would
keep a steady 3.2 gigahertz and we
thought that was because apple wanted to
save battery with this system that
definitely helps not to running at peak
wattage and also that there were some
thermal limitations with some throttling
we made videos about that now with the
new mac studios we knew that we have
some of the same chips and without
having to worry about battery life and
with having this new beefy cooler
that literally runs the cpu at 60
degrees celsius and the gpu even lower
in our benchmarking tests
they could give it a lot more
performance and not worry with
throttling and make it such a great deal
for 2000 bucks for this base model
that you get better performance quieter
temps and it's an amazing machine now
let's go ahead and look at the facts
starting off with geekbench 5 here the
performance is actually slightly lower
than in the macbooks within margin of
error maybe it's because of the ssd
being not on the motherboard but it is a
little bit lower now in terms of
cinebench here this is where the power
was limited or the frequency for the cpu
and we see that the performance is very
similar and when we look at the actual
frequencies it still drops down even
though it is running so cool and plugged
into the wall now as far as real world
applications that hit the cpu for
example lightroom photo editing and
exporting the times are the same same
thing with computer programming that
hits a cpu there is no performance
difference between these systems now on
the gpu side we have a couple versions
of the m1 max i said this is the base
model and the macbook that i'm going to
show you some of the results from are
also the 24 core version that is a
better deal on the macbook side now for
those of you guys that need extra
graphics performance compared to the m1
max and you're wondering how does the m1
ultra compare well we are going to be
doing a video with the m1 max and the m1
ultra both versions compared to the best
macbook pro to show you if it's worth
spending the extra money in getting a
desktop instead of a laptop for your
specific use case so if you guys want to
see that super interesting video make
sure you guys click the subscribe button
down below now as far as the graphics
performance between these there's no
difference doesn't matter if it's
blender doesn't matter if you're gaming
and it doesn't matter for video editing
even for things that just absolutely
hammer the cpu
there's no extra performance difference
now we know
the actual wattage of the gpu also was
limited in the macbooks and even the 14
inch macbooks especially with the m1 max
models they are actually clocked lower
on those to save battery life and to
help with heat now looking at this
computer here the mac studio
it seems like the same limitations for
the laptops have been placed in here and
what proved it to me
was when i ran the absolute most
difficult test which maxes out the cpu
it's decoding raw with the cpu and then
encoding and down scaling to 4k from 8k
with a gpu now in the macbooks the 24
core almond max actually beat out the 32
core because of how much thermal
throttling was happening and instead of
running at about a thousand megahertz
for the 32 the 24 ran at 1
1250 so we got some throttling and it
was running at like 95 degrees celsius
now i expected this
mac studio to do much better in this
torture test that takes over seven
minutes
but
it actually was four seconds
slower
and with that not only do we have the
same limitations of the cpu uh we're not
getting any extra performance but
the actual down clocking here also
happened and it didn't run at the full
1300 it ran at 1250 as well
even though we have more had room for
gpu power usage uh it's running
literally the gpu is running at 61
celsius the hottest gpu cluster the cpu
is running at 71 degrees celsius and we
are running at base fan speeds so what
this tells me and what we verified with
the other mac studios like the m1 ultra
is that with this specific chip
for people that are want to buy the m1
max versions apple they are not
giving you any extra performance and
they literally took the same exact
tuning from the profiling and the the
wattage and limitations from the laptops
and they put the chip in here without
any changes now why would they do that
well there's a couple options one there
could just be hardware limitations um
but because we tested out the m1 ultra
chip that seemed to do better like you
had different tuning two it could be
because
apple wants the same chips to perform
the same across the board so you choose
the performance ship you want the
graphics and doesn't matter if you buy a
macbook or a mac studio with way better
cooling and no battery they are going to
perform the same to give you consistent
results and three
what i think is probably happening is
if apple went ahead and took this chip
and gave it extra performance let her
get a little bit more gpu power usage to
be able to clock faster and not be
limited both cpu and gpu well that would
make this quite a bit faster than the
mac uh macbook make it even better of a
deal but when the m2 came out it
wouldn't be that much of a performance
increase but since they're keeping this
chip
locked down just like the same
performance as the macbooks when that n2
comes out
it is going to have a much bigger gap in
performance if they go and raise the
clock speeds for the gpu and the cpu and
they increase the architecture
efficiencies so that is what we ended up
finding out don't expect any more
performance and with that
the limitations that we have in some of
the tests they are still here they could
have added a little bit more gpu power
and not had that limitation
they didn't the tuning is identical
now why would you want to buy the
macbook pro well you are going to spend
a little bit more money in the case of
the 16-inch that'll be 1100 bucks if you
want to spec it the same that's a lot or
900 if you're getting a 24 core for the
14 inch which i would i would not get
the 32
but you are getting a display
that is extremely good better than any
laptop display out there and with the
mac studio you will never get a display
displayed this good even if the sixteen
hundred dollar studio display
does not compete quality wise to this
1600 knit brightness display with that
you're getting some great speakers
you're getting a webcam that's much
better than the mac studios you're
getting the keyboard you are getting the
trackpad you are getting a battery and
of course you could take it with you in
the past when you did these kind of
comparisons it was always like well the
laptop it's louder it's hotter it's
quite a bit slower uh the screen was
nowhere near as good the speakers
weren't as good as they are now but you
can take it to go the desktop well you
know it's a lot better a lot faster but
you're locked down in this case now with
these new machines
you don't get any more performance now
you will end up losing some of these
ports instead of getting four
thunderbolt and two usbc two usba's
you're gonna be limited by three and
then you have the sd card reader of
course separate charging point port but
if you're gonna be taking a laptop and
docking it at your desk you can get an
inexpensive thunderbolt 150 bucks dock
gives you three extra thunderbolt ports
because these all have their own
controllers so they'll give you usb type
a
that can be fixed pretty easily now
you'll deal with a little bit more fan
noise for the situations where you're
maxing out the cpu engine the gpu it's
also pretty rare for most workloads
usually it's one or the other
so now i would just say
unless you want to get a m1 ultra or
unless you definitely don't care about a
laptop
this is a much better bang for the buck
even though you'll pay a little bit more
so much more flexibility and you're not
losing any performance compared to
getting a desktop machine so there you
guys go go ahead and click that circle
above if you want to see that triple max
studio with the ultra against the best
macbook pro video check out one of those
great videos over there this has been
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]